what do you think
about this moment in history which was
uh really troubling to me
we could talk about several troubling
aspects but
one is uh amazon removing parlor from
aws
to me that was the most clearly
troubling
it felt like it created a more dangerous
world
when the infrastructure
on which you have competing uh medium of
communications
now puts his finger on the scale now
influences
who wins and who loses absolutely you're
right
and what you're always told is like if
you don't like twitter create your own
service
right or if you don't like something you
can do your own thing or if you
are uh and and and basically because
you know tech you have to be in business
with one of five companies i think it's
like amazon facebook google
uh youtube and twitter whatever they're
like you know i mean amazon puts
everything on the cloud
you know google and youtube it's it's
all basically the seo and the
advertising and you got to get your name
out there you don't want to be buried
and
like because you have to do business
with you're it's a cartel of these
companies you understand it better than
anybody
uh that you are prevented truly and i
i think whatever you think about parlor
whatever you think about what people are
saying on parlor
whatever you think about uh alex jones
whatever you thought about milo
yiannopoulos
the state has an interest in and has
always had an interest in in
crushing dissent this is what the state
has done this is how they
you know retain the power they have
by eliminating dissent where they can
now because you don't have
you know three broadcast networks
anymore and a handful of newspapers that
were all
run by the way by people that had been
either compromised
or happily you know happily going with
the program
and you have this wild west of the
internet
people like me people that make i make
funny content that i hope is funny but a
lot of it is wild and crazy yeah i say a
lot of wild and crazy things
they're very funny i say a lot of wild
and crazy things about powerful people
yeah you mock the powerful in there by
bringing them down a notch
we'll probably talk about it but humor
is one of the tools yeah to to
to uh to balance the powers
in society well sure or and to make
people feel better about things and to
you know whatever the case may be right
that's my goal is to kind of like hey
people have had a shitty day
if this video or podcast makes you laugh
that's great
i think that it won't ever it was never
going to stop at alex jones not that
i think he should have been taking off
everything the way he was
but this keeps going until we have
sanitized
all of social media and they what they
really want it to be
is what instagram is kind of becoming
which is a marketplace
of you could just go and buy sneakers go
buy a sweatshirt
go buy jeans go buy this go buy that and
the idea of the free exchange of
information
seems to be the old internet and it
seems the new internet seems to be
uh you know hyper and i'm a capitalist
but this is
like hyper capitalist in the sense like
they only want you consuming things
and they don't want you thinking too
much
and that seems to be worth heading i've
even seen that with instagram where it's
like everything on instagram is not like
buy a sweatshirt yeah you know and i'm
like
all right man hey man if i want a
sweatshirt i'll get it like relax
you know just every ad seems to be
encouraging consumption but very few
things seem
geared towards hey
let's have a dialogue or less and not
that instagram is ever great for that
but like
very things are geared now towards
content on instagram a lot of it seems
geared towards
shopping see i don't know it's an
interesting point i don't know if the
consumerism that capitalism leads to is
necessarily gets in the way of nuanced
conversation
i feel like you could still sell tim
dillon sweatshirts
and have a difficult nuanced
conversation or mock
the current president the previous
president mock the powerful
all that kind of stuff we try we try to
balance that i mean we have sweatshirts
we do would you they're not are they on
sale now business
uh we do a fake business sweatshirt with
the enron logo fake business because i
like i do fake business all the time
would be nice if we talk about alex
jones if you plug
the sweatshirt during that conversation
yeah we'll do that absolutely yeah
you